I was good it's your boy smino check me
out on a bootleg cab podcast you know
bootleg cab show special guest in here
smino
what a dude kid welcome man welcome
first of all you just showed me uh
congratulations 90 proof is like the
number three biggest debuted song on
Spotify for the week yeah not just rap
just a song genres yeah it's just uh
just yeah that's hard that's huge man in
the U.S appreciate it bro how's that how
does that feel
it's cool it made me want to do some
Moto you know what I'm saying I'm just
trying to see what else I can get up you
know what I'm saying get accomplished
how did you uh cause like obviously
um you know going back to those
dreamville sets and [ __ ] like that was
would you say that that was kind of like
the origins of you like locking in with
Colin building that rapport with him
yeah um that's how I really got to tap
in with him but Loki uh I think my
relationship with Jude like was my
relationship with dreamville in general
That's my boy so uh yeah bro like
like he was having a lock-in just in L.A
and just attacked me then I turned
around and just called it I [ __ ] with
you I'm like [ __ ] I [ __ ] with you
that's crazy you know and that's how I
got cool bro but um of course the
sessions down there I made up everybody
wagon more cool he made a whole lot of
[ __ ] like brothers yeah that's what it
feels like I feel like everybody's it's
like it was like a fraternity of whoever
was able to like be lucky enough to be a
part of those yeah no [ __ ] for sure like
a fair house bro yeah for real I heard
like uh Giannis was there man yeah I'm
in there I'm talking about Chris Bosh
behind Chris I heard Chris Bosh was
making beats yeah making beats and
Backwoods all kind of [ __ ] going crazy
bro yeah Ludacris was just standing
behind me one day because you would just
be selling your bag you don't realize
who running around that [ __ ] but
yeah that's all that was in there they
was like 19 at the time what was uh
Chris Bosh like
he was in that mug chilling and he was
making beats he was telling everybody my
name Chris
we know buddy yeah nah but like yeah one
of my homies did we was on some funny
[ __ ] we on some Chris box looking ass
[ __ ] like you know what I'm saying we
looking at them but one of my homies
didn't think he was really Chris by show
he's just like oh you you guys were like
yo look at this Chris Bosh looking
muffin yeah he like Chris but yeah we
fried we like this ain't Christmas [ __ ]
you don't rap yeah but I guess you do
well he raps I think he produced he he
tapped in how were the Beats I ain't
heard no Christmas beats hmm I want to
hear some Christmas you know who has a
NBA producer who has some of the worst
beats I've ever heard that made it on
the major labels or major albums Chris
Webber he had a daughter he had a beat
on Nas's uh hip-hop is dead album that
was so atrocious
you know what's funny is I'm from the
West Coast so God I was a little more
popular on the West Coast
but I never I never could do it the
anti-speed that was the Latrell spree
with the Spree Wheels yeah that was an
error Supreme
I had no doubt uh you didn't have any uh
you know I mean you know there you know
who's dope JaVale McGee's a dope
producer Javale McGee cool peoples bro
and he's got dope beats yeah down there
in Phoenix right now right not anymore
he's with the Mavericks now I'm a Sons
yeah he got signed in the offseason
unfortunately this this year yeah yeah
this off season yeah oh that's cool but
um I know that [ __ ] might be but it
made sense he had hit me up before just
awesome like what's good but I feel like
everybody in the lead that hit me up
they probably make music now that I
think about it that's hard for sure what
is your team in St Louis
the Celtics that's interesting the St
Louis Celtics yeah you know how we
coming man I was at the finals game last
year man my my boy JT you know I'm
saying we ain't we ain't bring her home
but we're gonna bring her home next time
you know I'm saying aside I mean listen
man the coaches out there bringing it
home for sure
hey man I don't know what to say bro
anybody I don't know what to say bro hey
eBay's outside bro I mean he's gonna be
outside on the couch but you know God
bless him email no damn cause that boy
got money he good yeah you're right it's
a nice couch yeah that's called a
bellini for sure on a bellini couch uh I
I only had one experience in St Louis
I went out there in like 2011 maybe
maybe 20 I was 2011. I went out there
there's a radio station out there that
tried to hire me uh a guy named Boogie D
was out there I turned the job down but
um
that night I ended up uh Freddie Gibbs
ninth wonder and Rhapsody had a show
that LRG sponsored and it was not a
popping show it was kind of it was kind
of whatever but after that me and Fred
went to East St Louis and we went to a
place called the pink slip you was it a
slip yes
he was in a slip they had you with a pen
slip yeah that's what's up you have fun
I had a great time yeah is that is that
uh have you been to the pink slip yeah I
want anything to sleep open no more is
it closed yeah I don't act about the
slipping online man that's some old
school [ __ ] I ain't did that in a minute
but I ain't lived in St Louis in a while
too but [ __ ] that's something you you
was in you was on some St Louis [ __ ] but
East St Louis different State Illinois
correct for people who don't know East
St Louis is in Illinois yeah that's
Illinois
then there's St Louis in St Louis is St
Louis U.S cycle we don't claim Missouri
St Louis USA then it's East St Louis
Illinois you don't claim Missouri yeah
that's a real estate we're a blue City I
guess or something like that but we
don't really be [ __ ] with the whole
Missouri wave that [ __ ] real racist and
[ __ ] up out there bro straight up I've
heard yeah Missouri terrible I mean it's
it's like a swing state so there's like
all all sides of the coin there right
like you said like the St Louis is
probably a blue City it's definitely a
swing States for a reason yeah St Louis
we're out of black people Kansas City
too like a lot of you know what I'm
saying St Louis County city but [ __ ]
even more south St Louis shout out my KC
[ __ ] though how far is Casey from uh
St Louis a couple of hours just a little
drive like when you're growing up right
obviously St Louis has had a successful
rap scene shout out to Natalie shout out
of the St Louis X Chingy Jaquan been
going on
um and then like obviously Kansas City
has like Tech Nine and the Strange Music
[ __ ] going on yeah I'll influence for
you by just all that [ __ ] in general I
was influenced by the lunatics and
nearly on some how to rep Saint Louis
you know what I'm saying and uh I think
I was influenced by my city in the same
way nearly was like where I'm from was
like some Soulful [ __ ] like our parents
listen to like a whole bunch of like old
Soulful [ __ ] like we all grow up in
church if you from the hood you you was
going to church or you was by church or
it was some people but from church
people around you so you feel me all
that [ __ ] kind of just inspired all that
singing [ __ ] you know what I'm saying
that bluesy [ __ ] you know yeah I think
Nelly uh successfully probably did like
real melody in hip-hop before most
people that [ __ ] was like probably
before everybody doing this your son now
yeah pick up the mic and put the drugs
down that's like one of the hardest
nelly songs ever bro yeah they're loving
me bro oh God and free city was an
underrated album yeah free City hard too
shout out to Murphy Lee man shout out to
the whole uh who else was from shout out
to Merv Dirty Man real [ __ ] he vegan
too he's vegan are you vegan no yeah
good for you hell nah I couldn't do it
man yeah I think he's vegan [ __ ] he look
vegan nowadays have you thought about
going vegan
um
I I eat some vegan meals I'm just not
gonna go all the way vegan I feel like
it's like a clean thing like I just eat
you know what I'm saying like maybe like
a week yeah when I've been bullshitting
with the tequila too hard you feel me I
think Tequila's vegan it's Agave for
sure for sure damn they're vegan but uh
I'll lick a vegan bro I would hope so
yeah like [ __ ] I'll look a vegan bro I'm
like is there something about because
you said it like you know if I've been
drinking tequila too much it's honey
Hennessy is just grapes you know what
I'm saying so it's like all this [ __ ] is
fruit you're a Tequila man nowadays yeah
I used to be a cognac it's a different
drunk isn't it
I just um I feel like home yet for when
you alone because the white cognac made
me tired and ready to be gone and out
that's I feel like that's why people
fight when they are Hennessy and [ __ ]
because they be down the tire it's a
violent drunk yeah yeah the kids a
little more fun happy drunk happy drunk
oh God
yeah I don't drink kids I think
something about the pandemic put tequila
on in a new way with like you know the
casa and the class Amigos and yeah
casamigos took off shout out to George
Clooney Clooney George Clooney that's
his that's his uh we was drinking 42 in
the panty though clone yeah I don't know
where that came from with that costume
you go [ __ ] but we was drinking 42 heavy
right before that [ __ ] everybody has a
little price yeah 42 is a little
overrated that came with that price it's
a little overrated it's about the bottle
damn yeah yeah crazy must have been a
rough night huh well I wasn't at all I
was drinking water in between bro that's
smart yeah I drank Jason much water you
know you're a professional when you take
your shot and then you take a big big
gulp of water and then you just do that
the whole night you should be all right
I've done and got OCD bro I can't be
remotely thirsty so I just drink water a
lot yeah you are you OCD with all
aspects of life or just hell no just
water like it was like if I'm thirsty
when I'm thirsty I I can't even go to
bed without seeing a bottle of water
first like I gotta see them then I go to
sleep like all right but I can't eat
unless like if I run out of a drink at a
restaurant I've stopped eating until
they remember refill
I have to have a drink with my food at
all times why you'd be scared you're
gonna need the Heimlich or something nah
just it's just I don't know bro it's
just I just like to eat with with drinks
I feel it I mean I feel it
um for people who don't know St Louis
because when I went there it was green
it felt like Real historic like it felt
like uh it just I never seen nothing
like St Louis it was pretty bruh it's a
real pretty city but but it's also I was
gonna say it's also like tops the list
all the time of like some of the
deadliest cities in America yeah it was
definitely a place that like I think
probably gets overlooked nationally in
terms of like just the scene and just
kind of what's going on there like um
what would you for you like being like
on the Forefront of the new St Louis I
guess who who some of the artists some
of the uh groups whoever that you you uh
you know are taking note to that are
from out there man for us I lose
uh I personally work with a few people
uh one of my homies my boy Jake baby the
great he hard my boy Barry of course I
always
um
this is [ __ ] night and Jordan Ward he's
super tight he from St Louis he's saying
though he do a little different [ __ ] I'm
real tapped in with like uh
like the side of St Louis that you
probably wouldn't expect to be there you
feel me which brought me you know what
I'm saying about but um
I don't know bro it's a hoe it's just so
much [ __ ] going on in the loop right now
bro like literally I went I was just
down in St Louis for a week you feel me
for the first time in a minute like I
ain't been able to go home for a minute
you feel me but I was just down there
for a week for a while and uh I booked
the studio and [ __ ] and I was just like
damn bro you feel me like all my all my
partners I went to uh school with they
they the ones that got the studios now
like they're the ones they got the crazy
friends
so yeah it's cool to see that [ __ ]
[ __ ] producing [ __ ] doing all kind
of cool [ __ ] so hopefully it'll be more
[ __ ] come out the crib we feed me in a
year to come I ain't say yours I said
the year to come too oh God what up
y'all we gotta stop the interview to
tell you about our new sponsors our
family at hardeen Las Vegas you see what
it is you see what it is welcome to the
family heart Dean man we're so excited
I've been going to Harding for so many
years for people who don't know Hardin
is that premium cannabis dispensary the
number one award-winning dispensary in
Las Vegas I'm talking the biggest and
best selection of cannabis product and
of course in Vegas but I'm talking about
worldwide they're them [ __ ] all
right so what you got to do is pull up
when you're in Vegas to Jardine go to
Harding underscore Las Vegas shoot them
that follow on Instagram go see them
tell them I sent you when you go to
check out be like yo bootleg Kev sent me
I saw y'all talking about it on the
bootleg cat podcast look when you're in
Vegas they'll also deliver right to your
room whatever you need all right make
sure you follow the crew Harding
underscore loss Vegas go to
hardinlasvegas.com that's j-a-r-d-i in
Las vegas.com and don't forget when you
go to Vegas you go to Jardin tell them I
sent you and they're gonna you only
might throw a little extra little eighth
in the bag or something a little
discount the bootleg discount you know
what I'm saying get them packwoods too
they give me a Packwood the other day
that geez I'm still recovering from that
[ __ ] blew my whole [ __ ] face off in
the best way Hardy in Las Vegas all
right shout out to them let's get back
to the interview talk about the title to
this album that's coming man love for
rent yeah yeah love for rent um I caught
that [ __ ] love for rent because yeah I
don't know we're trying [ __ ] out that's
where I said right now we just trash it
out love for rent like
basically like it's really supposed to
be like the whole concept is what I told
what I what I I already said this [ __ ]
but I'ma say it again the whole concept
is like where is it you feel me I give
love out
to the point where I have enough to get
that [ __ ] back to myself you feel me and
uh
I kind of wrote it from that perspective
but like I wasn't trying to be so like
um
what you call it uh
introspective about love more so just
honest about like my my real actions and
what I was doing in the time while I was
affected by that feeling if that makes
sense that makes sense yeah
so you gotta have that water yeah always
got to stay hydrated man
[Music]
but yeah that's what love for rent about
that [ __ ] fired me though it's real fire
it's a great name yeah yeah it's real
far outside of J Cole any other features
of course there are yeah we got a whole
lot of features uh actually a lot of
cool [ __ ] on the album um
give us one
and we get one one
uh who who who I think um give me a
rapping ass [ __ ] that's on your
album a rap feature there just a rapper
someone who could rap their ass off I
know somebody's rapping their ass off on
that album
oh [ __ ] me
um and then uh I say Lil Uzi Uzi okay
Uzi rapping on my [ __ ] I think uzi's
rapping around I think Uzi be getting
like not enough credit in terms of like
how good of your rap because he could
sing yeah he's singing and [ __ ] he got
like other ideas so I feel like you know
when you ain't no rapping ass this is
what I do I rap and I want to rap better
than you ass [ __ ] people gonna try to
play that's me [ __ ] [ __ ] be
trying to play with me bro I promise you
everything I love I probably didn't see
it cold as [ __ ] than most [ __ ] but I
sang that [ __ ] so it come across like
you said you have it come across but how
did you and Uzi link up
he liked my song I deserved he had
posted the balloons from the video and
[ __ ] and uh [ __ ] I just randomly was
smoking outside the studio I was in the
studio with uh saba and no ID and I was
outside smoking and [ __ ] this [ __ ]
black truck just pulled up damn
but like stop next to me then [ __ ]
jumped out this [ __ ] Uzi and [ __ ] and
he was in the room next to me so he
walked in the room and [ __ ] I went in
with him I was like bro I got this song
and I said your name in the hood let him
play for you I played it for him
and he hopped on it I was leaving to go
uh go to a little dinner and [ __ ] before
I got out the Uber for dinner he he sent
me the song Jesus that [ __ ] did that
[ __ ] like 10 minutes [ __ ] wow it's hard
though I love how you just pass over
like you were in with no ID and you know
no ID is one of my favorite producers of
all time so shout out to no ID
no idea Sabo working on anything I was
there you were just there I was wrapping
my ass off in there too though yeah
shout out to shout out to no ID who else
uh the coldest thing about no idea is
that this [ __ ] named Dion and n-o-i-d
it took me so long to know that that's
so hard it is hard that [ __ ] genius it
is genius Chicago [ __ ] shout out to
Chicago shout out today
um who's handling production on this
album I need any producers that you can
shout out I mean yeah Monty Booker my
boy groovy he did the uh Groove did this
uh 90 proof that just came out yeah my
boy Felix Kyle Banks childish major
and myself them the producers it's all
it's all internal [ __ ] am I missing
somebody
yeah that's that's I think it's I think
that's yeah when you like can handle
some of your own production is it like
you know we think of some artists who
kind of came in the game as producers
and then there's guys like J Cole or
crit who like were have been doing both
kind of the whole time like they're more
known as an artist would you ever
produce for other artists or like even
like oh you go down that Avenue where
you like make it a thing where you're
like pitching beats to like artists and
[ __ ] I wouldn't be I mean everybody's
ever been in the studio with me
understand uh how what I do in the
studio you know what I'm saying so right
I think it'll be more of a thing where
I'm just like let's just lock in see
what you trying to do let me let me try
to help help steer the ship on something
creatively with you yeah let's just
figure it out that's what I'll be at
like I love working with people in
collabs I think I did like 30 [ __ ]
collabs last year I'm on a lot of apps
I've been out of town it's crazy I kept
going to uh we was in Atlanta New York
whatever but everybody on tour right now
so I've been just performing a bunch
with the homies and [ __ ] so that [ __ ]
got me thirsty Couture that got me back
though you got a tour coming up yeah
yeah yeah
announcing soon
Loki uh any damn day now yeah we finna
announce it with the album and all that
are you headlining yeah but I'm doing
like a uh it's like a like a co-head
line Vibe you feel me it's gonna be lit
on the game when will this tour
announcement happen because by the time
by the time this interview comes out it
might already be out do you guys have a
date yeah yeah yeah let's go we're gonna
announce that [ __ ] real song I don't
really give a [ __ ] y'all do what y'all
want to do no I'm saying like you [ __ ]
gonna come through y'all said
y'all heard her first y'all heard there
first you don't matter bro but we finna
go crazy bro we're gonna be back on you
I don't know I'm just throwing names out
there I don't know I'm just I'm just I'm
just fishing you know what I'm saying
anyway uh that'll be hard though
yo it's bootleg cab here to tell you
about our partners at my bookie damn it
football season we're in the thick of it
right now I hit big last week too man I
want to give a shout out to uh to my guy
who gave me the picture out of my guy
sports book Killer but listen what you
got to do is go to my bookie right now
get in on this NFL action you know NBA
is coming up too you could bet on
anything you want they got the player
props you could do the a parlay Builder
you could bet on your favorite team to
win the Super Bowl get them odds up
whatever it is the most important thing
get that first time deposit bonus that
means when you sign up for your account
use the promo code bootleg
b-o-o-t-l-e-g and you will get a deposit
match so if you put in 200 they're gonna
give you 200 on top of that to gamble
with for free if you put in a thousand
dollars they're gonna match that deposit
with a free thousand dollars for you to
gamble with right now so what the [ __ ]
are you waiting for let's get this money
let's watch some [ __ ] football and
let's get paid with my bookie who's your
favorite it's been a pretty dope year
for music
outside of your album that has not come
out yet what's your favorite album of
the year or your favorite albums of the
year
stay Lucy
Steve Lacy's incredible
um
damn let me look at my phone bro I I
gotta see what I've been listening to
but it'll be so much [ __ ] going on in my
head
because I've really been [ __ ] with
social media there's been some great
ones I think forever stories up there
Kendrick's album I like yeah I like I
like Jade I'm a lot too the new Freddie
Gibbs album is crazy I ain't heard the
new Freddy yet that [ __ ] just drop right
Triple S yeah shit's heart
um
stay lazy and when that one album come
out from them boys can I call you Rose
did that was that this year
I think that dropped issue
man something in the indications man
what's that line bro let's be some salt
cycle sauce oh yeah the secret sauce my
bad my bad
hold on
I gotta see if it did yeah these [ __ ]
drive if this drop this [ __ ] this might
be my fear yo this Microsoft but I don't
even understand why this [ __ ] this far
but this [ __ ] five but they got five
[ __ ] uh but still like she probably had
the most interesting [ __ ] to me this
year because yeah he's a very unique
artist I feel like he's got a dope that
just it doesn't remind me of many people
you know what I mean that's very it's
kind of like you I feel like you guys
are
very one and the same in terms of just
like
when I hear you I know it's you yeah and
there's not a lot of people that can
sound that sound like you I suppose
before or after you know that's tight
bro yeah I felt with Stage I'm gonna say
Steve you probably might have my
favorite [ __ ] yeah shout out to him man
shout out to him uh do you feel like
with like now that we've kind of gotten
over the pandemic was there anything
that you were missing as an artist
during that time that is kind of like
kind of adjusted the way you're looking
at the music business because you know a
lot of artists
they they depended on going and getting
bags at the club or the live shows or
you know we heard of a lot of artists
like who were kind of hurting during the
pandemic was there anything that like
you kind of took from the pandemic that
you're able to kind of apply to your
your business model as an artist now
moving forward or anything you learned
huh
I feel like bro I was pushing through
the pandemic super smooth like I don't
know I probably just got more if
anything I got just more uh
detail like I know more about my actual
business like my everything that goes on
it's important yeah I know more about my
ship like than anything like I know
about every part but um I say that's it
because through the pandemic we was we
was good I actually I was decent in the
pandemic bro like I'm because you know
what I'm saying like
I built a brand outside of just being a
rapper so
through that [ __ ] I can like it's like
another just whole thing bro like that's
like a whole different life for me like
I sell hoodies I sell clothes and [ __ ]
like that so that [ __ ] brings a whole
different type of thing to my Revenue in
my whole other Revenue stream yeah so
that's pandemic proof I mean I think
music is pandemic proof it is pandemic
proof but however touring though touring
is not yeah and it was like touring my
favorite part of this [ __ ] touring in
the studio all the [ __ ] in between that
turns into business I hate that [ __ ] I
hate music business I hate the business
I love the fact that you know what I'm
saying I'm able to exist in this [ __ ]
and I've been on for about five six
years now like sign you know I'm saying
I was with Interscope now with Motown
shout out to them but like you know what
I'm saying I I think the business is
kind of it just affects the talent at
all times like for a lot of people I did
a lot of uh I guess a better way to
answer your question is
um I did a lot of like uh
like purifying myself of the [ __ ]
from the business and cleansing my
[ __ ] mind from that [ __ ] and
like
I think my album turned in a better
Direction because I feel like the album
I was gonna drop like while I was still
in the road like before the pandemic and
[ __ ] was just like all right because
it's been a few years since we got an
album right yeah so like four years that
shit's crazy that [ __ ] just was
more so like oh yeah [ __ ] I'm finna be
the biggest like I felt it like I felt
like I felt my momentum I'm like this
[ __ ] finna go crazy I'm like my next
[ __ ] going crazy so I think I made songs
that was gonna like sound good like to
the world opposed to just like going
inward like let me like try to make my
bed so this is like the album we're
gonna get is kind of like the second
iteration of of an album third the third
version of man this album so it's funny
because this album I'm talking about is
all the way mixed and Mastered by that
[ __ ] Ali you know yeah I know yeah I
know Ali bro it's mixed and mastered and
[ __ ] like we mixed and mastered another
album which is the album that's coming
after this uh love for rent album and
[ __ ] so you already have albums in the
can just ready to go yeah you think been
doing bro I mean it's been four years
yeah like I've been in the studio [ __ ]
be like you need to ride to the studio
drop the album I'm like man [ __ ] shut
up I've been in the studio every day
like you feel me I don't where the [ __ ]
else I'm gonna go so this album comes
out how much longer before you drop the
other one I ain't back I ain't so that
that was not on purpose though like that
whole thing like I said I switched
labels you feel me and out a lot of
people like man he's going through labor
[ __ ] hell nah we having our way really
like it's more so just like
I was just trying to be smart and like
build a report with the people that I'm
gonna be working with next and I ain't
trying to just be stepping because I've
seen how I wasn't really like able to
move how I wanted to in the last [ __ ]
because you feel me if everybody ain't
on the same page it don't work and like
I said like I learned a lot about the
business and what to what to use and
what to not use you know what I'm saying
yeah I think sometimes like when you're
an artist and you're on a major level
you have a team
like and all you're doing is worrying
about the creative part sometimes [ __ ]
gets kind of like like falls through the
cracks whether it's like features
whether it's like you know certain
communication with other people's camps
because I always hear that show would be
like yo I was in the studio with
so-and-so
and now now his now his label ain't
clearing the record right and it's like
yo sometimes like yeah that really ain't
got [ __ ] to do with the artist ah bro
like you know what I'm saying this be
weird bro yeah it'd be super weird so
many songs that ain't gonna come out the
job [ __ ] Never Gonna Hurt cause
[ __ ] just one clear [ __ ] and would you
just be down to leak that [ __ ] I mean
obviously not you but like an anonymous
DJ man I don't I don't know that sound
incriminating bro
I don't know about that I missed the
days we used to just get random like
songs leaked with like hella [ __ ]
random like websites drops all over them
I mean that [ __ ] scared me bro yeah [ __ ]
they didn't got my [ __ ] bro what else
they got like
[ __ ] burn the iCloud have you ever had
anyone leak any of your [ __ ] yeah bro
they they leaked uh
some [ __ ] one of the songs that's on the
side we got leaked but it's cool [ __ ]
it's fine I'm like that [ __ ] so far so
how does how do you think that happens
because nowadays people text songs so
often I'm not gonna say how I think it
happened I tell you to the side because
if I tell you how I think it happened a
[ __ ] might not have thought like that
and be like oh okay I think like it
happens a lot because people will record
at Studios and then when they leave they
just leave the session and their [ __ ] on
a car that's what I was gonna say why
you said why you getting them game bro
nah that's what I was gonna say bro look
I have a recording studio we're sitting
in my studio now you know how many
artists have recorded like
I mean I've had like major artists
record here yeah and then nine months
later their team reaches out and be like
hey could we get our sessions from last
year and I'm like y'all didn't take them
nine months ago but obviously I give it
to him but it's like the fact that like
I like this dude's half of this dude's
album has been sitting on my [ __ ]
computer thank God it's me who had it
but like you know some of these Studios
people will be working in are [ __ ]
weird yeah Engineers are weird interns
whoever okay got deleted doesn't even
worse that's worse because what if the
[ __ ] what if what if you're depending
on my computer not to crash and me to
have a backup just get your files bro if
you just get your files just get up out
of here with the files bro that's the
main way that [ __ ] happened bro 100
[ __ ] you tweaking at the studio but if
I get a new intern he said we sweeping
till one in the morning just to get that
file buddy like I'm sweeping this same
spot to this [ __ ] [ __ ] talking about
hey what up y'all it's bootleg cab here
to stop the interview sorry uh but we
gotta pay the [ __ ] bills and you know
not only do we have to pay the bills but
we also got to take care of them [ __ ]
out there that's right make sure you go
to bluetooth.com right now you know the
bootleg kept podcast we are presented by
bluetooth proudly I happen to every once
in a while dabble in a little chooski
you know what I'm saying and let me tell
you something my dick thanks me for it
every single time uh so listen if you go
to Bluetooth use the promo code bootleg
you're gonna get your first month's
supply for free now we're talking the
same active ingredient as Viagra as
Cialis without the awkward doctor's
appointment visit you just go online
they get you taken care of it gets
delivered right to your [ __ ] door and
discreet packaging it's a beautiful
thing and how about this
brand new product alert on Bluetooth all
right and I'm gonna [ __ ] this up for
sure so I'm gonna try to read it uh now
Bluetooth has a mint flavored chewable
with
bardenophil which is the same active
ingredient in Levitra and stackson
so shout out to Levitra
same active ingredient in the mint
flavor chewables so what are we doing go
get you a little mint boy go get you a
little blue chew whatever the [ __ ] you
need just know
whatever young lady or man or Etc that
you're dealing with they're gonna
[ __ ] thank you for it because your
dick's going to be harder than it's ever
been in your whole [ __ ] life man it's
gonna be great and like if you're a
single guy
take a blue chew
jack off
be a better jerk I'll tell you that all
right bluetooth.com go right now
and uh you know I know we have a lot of
male listeners who like underground raps
so chances are you're not getting a lot
of [ __ ] but I promise you one thing you
take that blue tree you're gonna beat
your dick like it stole something all
night long bluetooth.com use that promo
code bootleg right now and they will
give you the first month for free so go
do that [ __ ] I see you have a black
panther shirt on I'm curious um
what are your thoughts on Kanye's
t-shirt that said White lives matter
today that he that he went viral for
wearing his uh fashion show
did you see it of course I'm saying this
[ __ ] I mean
um white lies I'm at a t-shirt yeah
look we're like I just I'ma just like
black lives matter bro obviously I'ma
just say that bro that's what I'm gonna
say black lives I'm out of gang I'm just
interested in like whatever his
explanation is because I saw a picture
it's gonna be some well the picture it's
gonna be some like you know what I'm
saying live in Buddha live in Christ
Vibes picture of the front of the shirt
was like a bunch of clan members
so I was just very confused I said I
don't know I do not know what the hell I
don't know bro the only clan that matter
is Wu-Tang um by the way
Wu-Tang Clan and knowledge are
performing in La is that tonight
that's right straight up yeah that's
tonight that's Hollywood Bowl damn for
real Wu-Tang Nas should we go and bust
the Rhymes we should go Busta Rhymes is
opening
that's actually hard the only thing that
sucks about the Wu-Tang aspect
is Method Man's not going to be there
you know we'll take businesses I mean
listen when there's nine guys yeah
somebody ain't gonna be happy I just
seen uh m-e-t-h-o-d man uh
um boy he went crazy that man ain't
missing B dexterity is impressive I saw
Method Man and red man when I was 12 on
the Hard Knock Life tour yeah I ain't
never seen red man floating through the
air on [ __ ] wires and [ __ ] and then
DMX came on and then it was Jay that's
how you know they've been smoking weed
yeah yeah they were smoking weed when it
was like the weed that we think is like
booth now is like their life where are
you from I'm from Phoenix
I will well you grew up on the west
coast yeah was it always Kush with y'all
or was y'all Smoking Reggie Reggie for
sure because I'm just like the way I'm
like the gas out here just crazy so I'm
like I'm imagining us growing up just
getting our hands on this [ __ ] smoking
like you know what I'm saying like
[ __ ] had to go through the Reggie days
to get to that kush days they had to you
know what I'm saying like but I'm like
damn these little [ __ ] just grow up
just straight up on crack like straight
up cursed out no those Reggie days were
I think about some how some of the weed
used to look back in the day success
back in the day wasn't it it used to
exist it used to look that weed used to
look crazy I seen some real Reggie in
North Carolina the other day I bet you
did that's a real ass Reggie bro I wish
I took a picture of that [ __ ] St Louis
is also another one of those like middle
of the country Mark markets that you
know
um got the gas right they either have
the gas or they have the some fruit
[ __ ] for St Louis he got that fruit go
the other way or may or may not know
from experience but let's just say
certain guys from certain cities might
come to LA and be like I just need
something that'll pass us indoor in my
city because
because I they don't know better out
there I'll be smoking gas some high-end
um you know lots of high-end light depth
[ __ ] Midwest bro ain't nothing to me
about the Midwest bro I just say that
some [ __ ] be having Reggie and you
know what I'm saying it happens but when
I was in Detroit
um
we were out there maybe two months ago I
went to the liquor store and in the back
of the liquor store uh there was a guy
who was selling
a fake eighth bags from like all the big
like Cali weed companies so there'd be
like an eight like you could buy an
eighth bag of like
runts or cookies or Gary Payton or
whatever and put whatever weeds you
wanted in it and the guy there was like
a line it was like a dollar a bag so you
could just buy whatever weed you get
stuff that I got that new cookie [ __ ]
and it could be anything in there but
it's sealed so do you how much you
selling for a dollar a bag for an empty
bag an empty branded bag
not a bad Hustle
yeah it was ready though no no they were
selling empty bags to people who sold
drugs
oh I missed the whole thing so imagine
you were saying brother imagine this is
a bag that says cookies on it and it's
baby blue you could buy
I think they did a deal if you buy like
a pounds worth of bags so you could just
stuff whatever weed you buy and then
stuff it in there and then you know
that's all yeah finessing the gun super
finesse that's smart super finesse okay
so uh album officially I win
um I'm about to announce that too okay I
ain't not sure yet but it's coming out
to announce everything October yeah
October we're in October man late
October bro
October man it's coming so with the last
Friday of October
so one of these days I'm gonna drop on
Fridays either bro what do you drop
you just dropped a song on a Friday
albums I never dropped the album on the
phone so what are you doing Monday
Tuesday Wednesday I did like going off
cycle with my arms just kind of just
okay four days a week I can't tell you
yeah Kev
you're going old school going Tuesday
like back in the day we used to buy CDs
man I like how you done you don't you
just keep asking because it's you know
what I'm saying so it's coming out on a
Tuesday nice
[Laughter]
taking it vintage old school yeah yeah I
yeah what he said but Tuesday uh uh
November 33rd you know what I'm saying
it's not a real day
not a real thing
November 33rd Tuesday 2000 and 2000. hey
I love your grills man are those like
obviously they're not perms
I said your teeth permanent oh teeth
your grill your teeth are they permanent
now that wood grain that's what it looks
like that will grind on that gold [ __ ]
but you could pop those out and in and
out when you want probably yeah do you
take up I mean obviously don't say
probably can you take them out I should
be able to
do you go to sleep with those in your
mouth whenever I lay down like
foreign
your dentist is not happy with you right
now you if you if if those aren't
permanent you should take them things
out I don't go to the dentist I go to
the tooth fairy
I see what you did there so what you're
saying is you're losing a lot of teeth
as a grown man no I'm not as a young man
I'm guiding teeth
like a baby or some [ __ ]
only no tea for a day well because I
when I lived in Florida like I had a
grill yeah and uh
that [ __ ] like you had to like take it
out clean it otherwise your mouth would
[ __ ] smell like funky yeah you think
oh man okay oh yeah I cleaned my grill
man I gotta ask you that is nasty yeah I
clean my grill I'll try not to smoke in
it unless I'm too drunk and I'm I'm just
belligerent what about eating in it
all right yeah that's trifling bro yeah
I feel bad for the guys to do like the
[ __ ] I was talking to see uh he's he's
got permanent teeth that's different
though no but he's he's he uh he's
removing them and going back to normal
teeth because he said it's just too much
maintenance it's got to be a lot of
Maintenance though because it'd be
diamonds too and it feels great like
your mouth feel your teeth feel it's not
as smooth you know what I'm saying but
no that [ __ ] wait if it ain't perms just
like you got it you guys you're gonna
not eat mm-hmm yeah
I like the wood green that's a red
that's original yeah man
eat it up
you already know hey you know the
[ __ ] be they bit my last Grill
my opal Grill Kim Kardashian stole that
[ __ ] Lynn Isaacs who else uh had this
[ __ ] uh which girl was this a lot of
people it was opal grill with the uh the
bus now they know that you know it's a
little though
yeah he pulled up on me and said like
yeah man I got the you know what I'm
saying like I seen them it's cool that
[ __ ] hard but Kim Kardashian show me no
love so that's that's like I'm I just
want Kim K to just you know what I'm
saying just showed up I mean all her
grills for oh God I didn't I've never
seen her wearing a grill she put that
[ __ ] on bro it's an October Baby thing
you know opal like a birthstone I think
she a Libra do you think uh Kim
Kardashian wearing a grill is cultural
appropriation
at this point now
now like at this point now when you say
at this point what do you mean it's just
at this point now like what like at this
point now it ain't like Kim Kardashian
wearing a girl is not shout out to Kim
too because I feel like she's done a lot
of good on the legal legal side to try
to get people out of jail oh yeah free
my uncle Kim on gang where you at Kyle
make it happen bro and free shorty Blood
please I'll be good we gotta stop the
interview tell you about our partners at
Odd Socks well first of all let's check
out the brand new collab
look at these the bootleg capsock you
see my pink ass face on those [ __ ]
socks nobody wants to buy those we're
going to figure out a way to give them
away though uh but look Odd Socks the
most comfortable socks in the world
um and the best thing about Odd Socks is
they're our family man I've been walking
with these guys for about 10 years now
and I will not wear anything else on my
feet like I swear to God I'm about to
take my shoe off I'm about to take the
look what is this
smells great too that's an odd sock
right there that's an odd sock basic you
know what I'm saying we [ __ ] with Odd
Socks you should too they got the crazy
licenses we're talking about Nickelodeon
shout out to Patrick [ __ ]
Cheez-Its Baywatch
how about macaroni underwear look at
these boys right here let's just crack
these [ __ ] open real quick what
do we got in here
come on man
yeah a little Pop-Tart underwear you
know what I mean yeah these are the Odd
Socks Basics all right so if you go to
the website right now order you some
underwear order you some socks use the
promo code bootleg Kev that's one word
all together bootleg Kev and you will
save 20 off at checkout go to
oddsocksofficial.com one more time
that's oddsocksofficial.com promo code
bootleg Kev and you will save 20 off
your order of course represented by Odd
Socks and we are proud to say so all
right let's get back to the interview
uh all right man well listen the new
album coming out on a Tuesday in October
late October
bruh funny that kid you funny well you
Kevin Hart I don't know what that means
uh he funny here album coming Kevin Hart
also real drop told a little overrated
as a comedian Kevin Hart Kevin Hart a
little overrated I'm a Bernie Mac type
[ __ ] like of course uh Bernie Mac one
of the goats DC Young flies probably
like one of the funniest [ __ ] uh like
just naturally like right now and then
like that whole I like I like that whole
Camp Carlos oh yeah the 85 South Side I
love them they're hilarious yeah I love
them bro they funny have you gone on
their show yet no I'm gonna make it
happen this time I went uh I met a bunch
of them when I went on while they're not
you watch a lot of podcasts yeah I like
I like pocket I feel like that's like
the route of [ __ ] right now to me it's
like cool podcast which podcast you
watch the most
Jing Champs drink Champs is the best
yeah I always drink shots the most I
don't like the Turk interview
yeah that Turk interview was just turned
up right away that mother that
[ __ ] he had a lot to say he had
a lot to say hey that [ __ ] was crazy
yeah that sounds crazy shout out to the
hot boys man legendary man you know what
I'm saying hot boy all them that's your
legendary man I was like a [ __ ]
three four years old but that's a
legendary my big sister jumping around
of that [ __ ] well listen man appreciate
you pulling up it's me know the new
record is out 90 Proof just debut top
three on Spotify
love for rent coming out
shortly so before November
but not
November where every
30 seconds
well listen love to run on the way y'all
tap in for real shout out kid man little
uzi's on the album so little nazex
[Laughter]
pulled up to the studio man we out there
it is